okay yep there's another Terminator
movie coming out I just saw I'm not
excited for this alright first let me
set it up we have a trailer for a new
Terminator movie coming out which is the
newest Terminator movie that's not gonna
live up to the first two Terminator
movies that retcons everything after
Terminator 2 Sarah Connor never died of
cancer she's still alive John Connor
where is he I don't know what is these
new people are on the run from a
terminator Sarah Connor shows up and
basically cleans house I actually really
liked what the new Terminator does
that's a really neat ability it has the
liquid metal skin but it has an
endoskeleton which is pretty much like
John Connor from Terminator Genisys and
the TX so it's like the TX the t xxx has
to be a porn of some kind somewhere but
no like the liquid metal skin can melt
off form another Terminator now you're
taking on two terminators that's
actually that's awesome why hasn't that
happened before this so I'll give the
new Terminator with that it's actually a
really cool ability it has it pretty
much does the noob saibot which I don't
know is it just the liquid metal skin
they're taking on now because it looks
like Sarah Connor does eradicate the
endoskeleton and I guess like she's a
terminator but not a terminator she's
like a terminator and a human which is
pretty much something from Terminator
Salvation it's like this movie looks
like it has concepts from the Terminator
movies they retcons but it's just now
put into one movie and the retconning
everything else and hopefully they do it
better too this time Arnold's back just
like Arnold back in one scene in this
trailer know everyone was looking
forward to seeing Arnold again he's in
one shot but apparently James Cameron
said now he is a t800 so he is a
terminator in this movie
he's like an old Arnold Terminator which
again is some taraf native Genesis but
apparently they're hoping they do better
this time currently John Connor is not
around he doesn't matter anymore this
girl now matters Sarah Connor was like I
was her at a point so apparently this
girl or this girl's kid is really
important in saving humanity in the
future so I imagine in Terminator 2
Judgment Day they just delay the
inevitable that is Judgment Day which is
something they did in Terminator 3 which
is doing again in this movie which
they're hoping they do a better I don't
know like these are the questions after
a trailer which I'm glad I have
questions after this trailer his clothes
are something aren't they I mean there's
something to be said about style like
Terminator 2 he was dressed like a biker
t1000 was dressed like a cop serve and
protect but it kind of made that it
profaned that concept this guy guys
shopping at a sporting goods store in
the fishing section
menacing is that the best I can come up
with granted he's gonna blend in just
fine and in execution in the movie it
might be awesome this might be the
coolest Terminator movie since 1991 not
saying much but a very well my face so
I'm glad Linda Hamilton's returning a
Sarah Connor that's cool does that make
for a good Terminator movie I'm glad
James Cameron's coming back to produce
not direct when they sail this is a
James Cameron fan but how involved is he
gonna be with this Terminator movie I
know he's these producer but the dude is
locked up with 4 avatar sequels right
now probably not very other than he's
producer which means the studio was like
can we put your name on it we'll give
you a pretty penny we just we need your
name on this next Terminator movie to
sell it I've seen him talk stuff up
before like Terminator Genisys he was
talking about how this is actually the
true Terminator 2 sequel
I feel like the franchise has been
reinvigorated the new film which in my
mind I think oh there's the third film
he's great at pitching stuff that's who
he is
so James Cameron being involved as
producer I don't know what that means to
what capacity that is beyond name only
so I just can't get excited about it I
like Tim Miller as a director I like
Deadpool so it's in competent enough
hands so it's just we'll see if the last
three Terminator movies hadn't let me
down so much I'd be super pumped like at
a point how can you have shitty
experience after shitty experience after
shitty experience and still be excited
for that thing this is terminator movie
number four after two the other three
suck I'm going with the math on this one
I I don't care about this I don't call
me Akram again anyhow Terminator dark
fate have you seen the trailer what did
you think about it whatever you thought
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more
[Music]